the Border gets politicized a lot you
hear a lot of like oh Caravans are
coming or children are being separated
from their parents or their families
take me into some of that scenario so
like if you apprehend a family then what
happens so everyone who's apprehended uh
and I'll walk you through from the point
of apprehension to to getting into the
station and in some cases criminally
prosecuted or released or returned
there's a couple scenarios as soon as
that arrest is made the agent
um and what we have to recognize is that
we're still dealing with a Criminal
element right so it's just like any law
enforcement officer he or she goes to
that whole procedure of pat down
checking bags and whatever else when you
have an organization a criminal
organization that's pulling in billions
of dollars
you know dropping five thousand or ten
thousand dollars in the pockets of a
Mexican official to look the other way
is nothing yeah so it this multi-billion
dollar industry
has a drive has a need to keep that that
uh that money coming in yeah so the
agents are contending with you've got
unaccompanied children and and when we
say this I want to paint the picture a
lot of these unaccompanied children or
young men between the ages of 15 and 17.
okay I'd say about probably half of them
and then okay rest
are everything from a 12 year old and
one of the things I see frequently is
you'll have eight or nine year old with
a younger sibling who's about five or
six and sometimes a two or
three-year-old with them and they're
traveling thousands of miles by
themselves to our border and then coming
across and it blows my mind I've got uh
an eight-year-old and I couldn't imagine
yeah saying here here's here's a phone
number when you get to the U.S call this
number and somebody's gonna come and
find you I couldn't imagine sending my
child out on this journey by himself oh
we had a four-year-old when I was
growing up that that wandered over to
our house like from the neighbors they
used to do a bunch of drugs next door
and um he knocked on the door he said he
was going to the Dollar General he's
like four years old we're like you're
not going to the dollars like this out
of his mind it's like two miles away
we're like this guys you know so we sent
him home man but so but yeah I can't
even imagine like a kid going a really
far distance out and it's hot over there
I mean I lived in Tucson for a while
dude it is it's spicy oh yeah and take
it back so if you're leaving from
Guatemala or Salvador Honduras you're
traveling a couple thousand miles two to
four weeks
I think about a six-year-old or an
eight-year-old doing this by himself or
maybe with a group of other kids
what happens between the the moment they
leave their house until they get to the
border and when you get to the Border
you're right there's the dangers of just
the environment by itself the Rio Grande
the desert the heat well the Heat and
the cold it'll kill you either or that's
a good point then you have people that
will take advantage of these kids yeah
and one of the things that just breaks
my heart because I've seen this
countless times
you get kids that are rented because one
of the things that happens is if you
present as a family unit
here's Roy mom a couple kids I'm gonna
get released and so what we were seeing
was kids being rented you know and and
so you've got a a parent back in
Guatemala who rents their child for
fifteen hundred dollars and that's a
tremendous amount of money in Guatemala
yeah
and so the kid
is brought to the Border put in with a
pseudo family sits in detention and then
is released and then a Handler a
Smuggler picks up this child
flies them back to Guatemala wow that's
that's the best case scenario right
right what happens with kids that just
disappear and we saw this happen as soon
as you identified that child because it
would take one or two sometimes three
times before the the system would pick
them up uh because not all children are
fingerprinted
and once you've identified them and you
you know you latch onto this group and
you expose it
if you can control and get that child
back into the hands of the parent
win if you can't if that child happens
to get released with that family and
then the smuggling organization realizes
that the child is now blown right I
don't know what happens to them yeah
it's like is it worth them fly get him
out getting them a plane ticket or a bus
ticket back to
Guatemala is it worth or is it just
cheaper for them especially after
they've already been doing a lot of
dirty business you know uh to just well
not care or get them into something else
even worse it's a business that doesn't
care about the person it's it's a
business that's driven by money so
whether it's trafficking whether it's
returning to the family best case
scenario and or becoming an indentured
servant you know working in some sort of
Industry being sexually trafficked all
of those are realities of what we see at
the border
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one